hey everybody
me again doing another flickers of fear
movie review
and this one this is another one that
i watched uh quite a while ago i think
it was in 2017
and i really really dug it and so i
wanted to
rewatch it and do it again for this show
as i've been doing the last couple of
weeks
now this is the netflix film i am the
pretty thing that lives in the house
now i'm gonna say right out front this
movie
like most movies i guess but this one
really is not for everybody
this is a very very slow
very atmospheric not very plot heavy
it's very ambiguous
it's a little bit literary so i kind of
feel like if that
is immediately going to turn you off
because i do feel like there's
um kind of wildly divergent uh critic
analyses of this where it's kind of like
some people just think
it's this great atmospheric mood piece
and some people are just like
it's boring pretentious crap so i really
liked this but i can
totally see how some people might not so
this is like not your cup of tea
this is very much like a creepy
visual poem i guess more than
a traditional narrative it does have a
plot it does have things happen
in it but it's pretty much mainly
focused around
mood and atmosphere and character to a
lesser extent
so as i said if that doesn't sound like
something that you'd be into then
absolutely i do not recommend it because
you will just probably
roll your eyes and like turn it off but
i really really liked this
so this movie was actually the second
feature film
made by osgood oz perkins who is the son
of
anthony perkins now interestingly though
the first feature film he made which was
the black coat's daughter which is also
terrific and i'm gonna um
review that one at some point as well i
saw that a couple years back
but for whatever reason i guess black
coat's daughter got picked up by a24
but they didn't release it until after
netflix had already picked up i am the
pretty thing and put it on their service
so it's been on netflix since a couple
days before halloween 2016 and it's
still on there
because it's uh they bought it i assume
so it's kind of like tagged as a netflix
original movie
and as i said if you're really into like
atmospheric slow burn creepy
kind of [ __ ] because there is like some
creepy visuals in this then i recommend
it if you have netflix however
on this uh review i'm probably gonna
spoil some [ __ ] although
i don't know this movie it's almost kind
of like because it's not
super plot centric i feel like it
doesn't really matter like if you spoil
it or not
because it raises so many questions of
like
ambiguity and so i think that you know
to discuss it properly
you kind of have to be able to say like
things that happen in it
and you know maybe bounce ideas off one
another about what
it all meant because there's a lot of
different uh
meanings that you could take from this
and i'm not entirely sure like which one
i subscribe to
maybe i'll come up with something like
the more i talk about it so yeah as i
said this came out in 2016. now
the setup of this is that there's a
live-in nurse
named lily saylor she's like a hospice
nurse she's played by ruth wilson
who i wasn't aware actually i know she's
been in a bunch of other [ __ ] but i
didn't actually know she was a british
actress
which i because she plays an american in
this because it's set in massachusetts
so i would never have uh i would never
have realized that so there you go i
don't know why like british actors doing
american accents they seem to be able to
do it like a lot better than
the reverse and i'm not really entirely
sure why that is but
that's neither here nor there so yeah so
she plays a hospice nurse named lily
and she has been hired to go to this
creepy old house
in it's not really a creepy old house
actually it's it's interesting like the
way it's from i'll get into that in a
little bit
but it's this house in braintree
massachusetts is a little bit remote
and the house is the residence of a
woman named iris blum
now iris blum used to be um a very
well-known writer of
horror novels suspense novels crime
novels stuff like that she's actually
played by paul apprentice
who i remembered very fondly from the
stepford wives back in the 70s
apparently um this was her first like
major role
in films in like 30 years because i
guess um she was like a family friend of
the perkins family and she said she
would do it
so she plays the elderly uh iris blum
who is seems to be suffering from
dementia and she can't really move
around
and uh she's dying so they have uh
you know this nurse come in to live with
her and take care of her
now the only other character well
there's two other characters but one of
them i'm not sure if they're real or not
so the only other character really in
this that's you know as a person is mr
wax cap who is
um kind of like i guess he oversees like
iris blum's estate he's played by bob
balaban
uh who's been in [ __ ] tons of movies if
you see even if you don't know his name
if you see his face you'll be like oh
that guy he's one of those actors
so he's only in a couple scenes as well
but that's uh he's kind of the one that
sets everything up
and then there's also another character
named
polly parsons but as i said we're not
really sure
if this is uh really a real person or
not
so when lily moves in we kind of
establish
she pretty much establishes there's like
a lot of voice over narration
in this which normally is kind of like
annoying but i kind of liked it in this
one because i thought it would
it just gave it this really creepy i
mean this is a really
eerie movie but you have to
kind of let yourself get immersed in it
because the way that it shot like the
cinematography
it just reminded me a lot of i saw a
really great review of this where
somebody i can't remember who it was but
i'm paraphrasing what they said
but they said this is basically like the
best adaptation of a shirley jackson
novel that never existed
you know what i mean so and i definitely
definitely think that was deliberate
because there are a couple scenes toward
the end of the movie
where they show iris blum as a young
woman
like in her office in the house writing
and she looks
very much like shirley jackson so i
think that they were trying to i think
that oz perkins was trying to evoke that
because this is a very very shirley
jacksony type of story
also has some kind of like in the
cinematography
um it almost kind of like evokes you
know kubrick maybe
or you know maybe david lynch because a
lot of the stuff
and i think i brought this up too when
we were talking about hereditary
is that a lot of the shots the way
they're framed it's like they'll do
these really really long
kind of floating shots like
of the house and there's always these
kind of like and the house itself
is actually quite bright and well lit
and it's you know all these
pretty like whites and neutral colors
and things so it's not like a creepy
decrepit
old haunted mansion or anything it's
actually quite you know sun lit
but when he shoots certain things and he
shoots like he'll shoot like a really
dark doorway
and it's almost kind of like the way
that it's shot so it's kind of like
almost evoking it's like maybe there's
something in those shadows and there's
not
usually at least as far as i could see
but
just the way that it makes you feel it's
just this kind of
patina of dread that kind of goes
through this hole because you're not
really entirely sure what the [ __ ] is
going on
in this house and particularly the way
it's shot i really really liked
and like i said i think this is maybe
why some people just thought it was like
pretentious boring crap or whatever
because there are like some really long
shots of just like empty rooms with like
an empty chair
and things like that but to me that
really seemed to
it made it like this really poetic
atmospheric it's
i don't know this movie just like really
really creeped me the [ __ ] out also i
really liked
you know because the very beginning they
have that really great shot
of you know the ghost who's supposedly
polly parsons
and she's just kind of moving very
slowly across this black background and
she's very kind of blurry and it's like
and it's just like really really great
like creepy creepy imagery like that
but as i said you really have to kind of
like immerse yourself in it otherwise
you'll just be like why are they
showing a three-minute shot of an empty
chair
i don't know it worked for me and i
should but i know it won't work for a
lot of people
so lily moves into this house and she
pretty much says
in her opening narration that she's
going to die
so you know that she's going to die by
the end of the movie because she pretty
much sets it up basically what she says
is
uh you know i'm three days away from my
28th birthday i will never have a 29th
birthday so you know that she's going to
die
at some point in the film so that's not
really a spoiler because they
tell you right away now they establish
that she's kind of
like i'm not really sure entirely like
when this movie was supposed to be
set i get it doesn't really matter but i
think it was
interesting that he kind of took the
route of
not really specifying what year this was
because when she comes to the house i
mean there's no cell phones
there's no you know the phone is still
one that's mounted on the wall
iris blum listens to music like on a
cassette tape
and the way that lily dresses could kind
of be
like nerdy 80s or maybe not like it
could be
like nowadays hipster like maybe all of
this old stuff is in iris's house
because she's old
but i think it's interesting how they
kind of have this so it almost has this
sort of like unstuck in time quality
because you're not entirely sure like
when
this is set like even i think the cars
look kind of older like when they show
there's brief shots of
uh you know mr wax cap arriving and i
think his car is kind of old
so i was assuming this was the 80s but
they don't ever tell you that
outright so lily's character they kind
of established from the beginning
that she's really she's like a big uh
scaredy cat
so because iris has all of these copies
of her novels like in the library and
she's
kind of wants to read them but she's
really really too scared to read them
and as she stays at this house she
starts to become convinced that probably
this house is haunted
at first it doesn't seem like much it
just seems like these kind of weird
thumping noises
and um at one point she's talking to her
friend on the phone
which is the really the only time that
she seems to be talking to somebody like
outside of this situation and you don't
really know i assume she's talking to a
friend or a roommate or something like
that and all we find out about her past
life other than her being a big scaredy
cat who can't even read horror novels or
she won't be able to sleep
is that she was engaged to someone
and it didn't work out we don't know if
that was her fault or his fault or we
don't know anything more about that so
like everything is just real
just it's all suggestion they don't
really she doesn't
have a backstory filled in iris doesn't
really have that much of a backstory
filled in
other than she was you know quite a
well-known writer back in her day
and that's pretty much it so everything
is just kept very very vague very
ambiguous
so you can kind of bring your own
interpretations to it i guess
so at this one point when it's night
time which is kind of like the first or
second night i think it's the first
night she gets there
and she's talking to her friend on the
phone and she's talking about yeah it's
you know it's kind of creepy i'm always
creeped out like my first night in a
in a new house or whatever and uh at
some point like the phone
sort of like snatched snatches out of
her hand
and she kind of like freaks out but then
she's like oh maybe i just dropped it or
you know maybe i had a spasm or
something like that
but it's just like real real slow [ __ ]
like that now
at some point she's actually at the
house over a period of 11
months like caring for iris now
interestingly iris insists on calling
her
polly even though she corrects her a lot
of times hey my name is lily i'm your
hospice nurse blah blah blah
but she basically um calls her polly so
when
mr wax cap comes one day like to check
up on stuff
you know she's like well who's polly
because she keeps at
she keeps calling me that and he's like
i don't she doesn't know anyone named
polly
she's like the only poly i can think of
was a character in one of her books
so it was called the lady in the walls
so
lily goes and finds a copy of the of the
lady in the walls and as i said she kind
of like reads the first part and then
she's like oh [ __ ] that's gonna be too
scary i can't read it
but indeed the character in the lady in
the walls is named polly parsons
and apparently according to the book
iris moved into this house which had
been built i think in 1813
and the story behind the house was that
there was a woman
named polly parsons and she got married
and her husband built the house for her
and then after they got married they
moved into it and they were only there
one day
and then they both disappeared and
iris's story when she wrote this book
was that basically
the ghost of polly parsons told her the
story that she was laying down this book
so she's saying oh this isn't a
fictional book
this is something that the ghost that
lives in this house told me
so as lily starts reading this book the
lady in the walls
she starts seeing or we start seeing um
manifestations of polly uh you know who
she's
just this beautiful like blonde girl
with like you know the 1813 she had a
wedding dress on
and there's like some really creepy um
visuals of her where she's kind of like
where her
and i think the one of the posters for
the movie like showed it like this where
like her top half is facing this way and
like her bottom half is facing that way
so she always kind of like walks like in
that weird way which i don't know that
like always freaks me out for some
reason
but uh so there's that kind of stuff and
then as it goes on there's some
flashbacks
where you supposedly discover that polly
was murdered by her husband who for
whatever reason as soon as they moved
into the house
bashed her on the back of the head with
a hammer and then hid her in the walls
like behind
the there's kind of like some paneling
there and that she's hid back there now
interestingly
in the present day if indeed that's what
it is
there's kind of like this weird it looks
like
mold or something and it's kind of
growing on this on the wall like
where you find out later polly parsons
was maybe
murdered and put behind that wall so and
it's interesting too because later on as
lily starts to kind of investigate
if this was actually a real case or not
she finds a box like in a closet that
says polly on it
and it has like the same kind of mold
and she finds in there it's like a
booklet that iris had
you're led to believe had like been
dictated the story like from the ghost
and it was like
like all handwritten and stuff and
that's where like the first draft of the
book came from
so it's really weird because
you're never entirely sure because like
i said there's kind of a lot of theme in
here of
you know lily saying that she's gonna
die so you're presuming that her
narration
is coming from after she's dead so lily
herself
is a ghost now as well so there's all
kind of stuff that she says in the
narration about
that the living can never truly like
live in a house that's
they can only borrow it from the dead
there's a lot of stuff in there about
the dead not knowing that they're dead
like thinking they're still alive um so
there's and there's
a lot of stuff about rot like she hears
like voice which is presumably polly or
it could be her we don't really know
talking about rot and about beauty and
and uh you know beauty rotting and
things like that so there's that kind of
stuff and she does have one really
creepy
kind of visual hallucination where her
the mold is like all over her arms and
their arms go all like bloated like
she's dead already
so it's interesting because they never
really it's never really established
whether lily is
polly whether polly was actually a real
person who was murdered in the house and
was indeed a ghost
which seems to be kind of like that's
what the through line is
but the way that they frame it and the
way it goes
along i kind of lean more toward
the theory that lily
was the ghost all along i don't know if
that's true or not i don't know if
that's the intention maybe he just like
left it ambiguous so people could
like i said bring their own
interpretations i interpreted it
as the whole story about polly parsons
and about her being murdered and walled
up in the house
i kind of thought that maybe that was
actually just a story
that iris blum had written but she said
it was true like it was like a fountain
footage type [ __ ]
like so you know so she said it was a
true story this so there wasn't really a
ghost in the house
but then when lily came to the house
hearing about the story
reading the story and kind of you know
there's
little ambiguous thumps and mold and
stuff on the walls and she's kind of
constructing this whole entire story
about it so it's like she almost makes
the ghost in her mind
because like i said they do establish
that she's a big scaredy cat
so she kind of makes this whole haunting
up in her mind which
in the end ends up killing her because
she dies
of fright basically she comes she hears
weird noises she comes downstairs
and she sees that all the boards have
been pulled off the wall
like where the mold had been and then
she sees
um you know she turns around and she
sees the apparition
of polly like in her eye and it you know
shocks her and she has a heart attack
and dies after which iris also
subsequently dies because she doesn't
have anyone to take care of her now
so at the end they show them like taking
both of the bodies away
so lily is a real person and she's
really dead
and the fact that she's having like
narration over this movie
leads me to believe that she is now the
one haunting this house
and then they kind of show that like a
family moves in subsequently with a
couple of kids
and like just the way it's shot makes it
seem like
now she's the ghost watching it but like
i said i don't really know
if polly parsons was an actual person
and an actual ghost or she was just like
a manifestation
of lily's fear and she invented the
ghost that ended up killing her
that ended up killing her in the end and
ironically making her be the ghost
that haunts the house now so it's kind
of like like i said it's a very layered
kind of piece and i love that kind of
stuff like it's very very shirley
jackson it just reminded me very much of
a shirley jackson
novel and in a way it's almost kind of
like
i've heard a lot of people call it
literary which it definitely is
it's almost kind of like a novel or like
a creepy poem
in movie form you know what i mean so if
that really doesn't sound like your bag
then i would not recommend it because
like i said it's very it's not a long
movie i think it's only
you know 87 minutes something like that
but there's a lot of like really
establishing like creepy kind of scenes
it's very very
low-key it's you know it's very much
like that
i think oz perkins like after this one
he actually made uh
gretel and hansel which came out a
couple years ago which i liked as well
tom didn't like it
but i don't think tom would like this
movie either he hasn't seen this one
but um you know he he just seems oz
perkins seems very very into
just these kind of like really eerie
mood pieces
that are you know not really all that
plot heavy like or plot centric
he's just more interested it seems like
in establishing
uh an atmosphere and leaving things to
the viewer's imagination leaving things
to multiple interpretations
and like i said i usually really like
that kind of stuff if it's done really
well
and i think in the ca in the case of
this movie i think it actually uh
was done really well because this movie
like i said some of the imagery in it
like the ghost imagery and stuff like
creeped me the [ __ ] out
and i just really really liked the whole
mood of it was just like so
so great but i definitely recommend if
you're gonna watch it if it sounds cool
to you
then kind of turn all the lights out and
watch it like don't have any
other noise or anything distracting or
anything like that because this is one
you really really need to
get completely invested in get
completely immersed in
and just kind of let it do its thing and
i think if you do that
like you'll find that it's like really
really creepy and really eerie and i
really dug it a lot so like i said it's
still on netflix um as far as
this recording because i just watched it
yesterday on there
because it's their movie so i'm assuming
it's not going anywhere
so yeah um definitely check it out if
that sounds like your kind of thing
and i will see you guys on the next one
bye